sept mois pour prendre conscience de soi
et des autres et construire un projet de
vie c'est le temps qu'a donné le
programme classes départ à ces jeunes en
décrochage je faisais pas déçu que
j'avais pas travail et je savais pas
vraiment vers quoi m'orienter ni où
aller ce qui me plaisait je savait plus
vraiment essayer de changer la vie de
ces jeunes leur donner énormément dans
vie le goût ou le coup au travail c'est
pas un c'est pas un gros mot on les
réhabituer à ce que après ses sept mois
ils puissent effectivement bas qu'ils
aient acquis le fait d'arriver à l'heure
de tout donner quand on est
effectivement
avec une équipe pour pouvoir créer
quelque chose de travailler dans une
entreprise
théâtre danse chant ou encore peinture
ces jeunes vont proposer une pièce
poétique écrite à partir de leurs
propres histoires des histoires souvent
difficiles qui parlent de leurs peurs et
de leurs blessures l'objectif se libérer
et grandir du passé pour mieux
appréhender le futur en cède et à la fin
c'est comme si
comme si on avait tout laissé sur la
scène et qu'on partait libre grâce aux
chants et aux danses et à tout ça au
théâtre
ça permet de s'extérioriser ça permet
vraiment de se découvrir soi-même à
travers l'art il y en a certains il
s'était en boule dans leur coin sans
parler à personne en arrivant quoi on ne
pouvant pas ella baché j'ai plus du tout
les mêmes plus du tout les mêmes la
pièce sera présentée au théâtre de
guyancourt à la ferme de bel ébat les 9
et 10 novembre prochain puis à leur ai
dit ça plaisir les 24 et 25 novembre
[Musique]